I really feel like if you're gonna do a
role whether it's dramatic or comedic
it's it's all sort of similar
preparation and similar a similar thing
I think the way to plan a joke and the
way to plan a sort of dramatic moment is
all about whether or not you're feeling
it and whether or not you actually can
connect to the moment so for me I don't
have any one thing that I I connect to
more than the other but this was
absolutely a blast to be a part of a
movie like this and to get to play a
character that's a little more
complicated and layered than I'm used to
playing so it was awesome
Terry great question um I much prefer
being in front of the camera acting has
always been the biggest thrill for me
and it's a it's been a lot of fun and
obviously a huge honor to be a part of
you know the show and to be a part of
these movies that I've done which is
fantastic but this I got to say gave it
a real run for its money to be actually
able to write with the guy who did
Google hunting and be directed by the
director of Google hunting as a Boston
boy that's a huge huge deal so I think
I've only seen the movie 178 times so to
actually be a part of this process with
them was amazing and so this was this
was as special as anything I've ever
done
to be honest it took me a second because
he is the guy in Google hunting it took
me a second to not be a starstruck as I
should have been and and you know we
worked really well together we worked
very quickly we had a similar sense of
humor and similar Sensibility and we
always knew where the script was gonna
go so we had a really good time writing
it we we I think we we got through it
very quickly in the same way but I will
say that the first day of shooting after
being his friend and then writing this
whole script together I had completely
forgotten until the first day I stepped
on set they're like oh right he's Matt
Damon he's a huge star so it took me a
second to recalibrate because I was a
little nervous to do my first scene with
him
you